The Dodges are going to go wild
[Applause]
5x can really erase everyone's hatred and
accept it. The
war has already begun. They
should have sent tanks, but you're going to
suffer.
Sasuke was by your side.  I've been trapped in hatred for a long time.
Who or that Sasuke could you have done?
[Music]
I mean, no
matter who it is, I'll erase the hatred. There's nothing I can do or accept.
[Music]  Are you
talking to me or what? I can't wait to see
you. You can't save Sasuke alone.
How can you be so strong? [Applause] If you question your decision, it's over. Sasuke will do something about it, and the war will end.  What are you
doing about it?
[Applause]
Hmm,
that Chinchikurin has grown quite tall,
isn't it?
Kyuubi from the ward. I'm
thinking that someday, I'd like to do something about Mikushi, one of the five of us.  It makes me
feel like I've suffered a loss. Do you
know that the snow in the car thread is dying from hatred?
[Music]
Bury yourself and fry it.
If it's the people around you,
squeeze it to the point where you're accompanied by a dick.
Lord Joy, I
'm a mass of hatred.  - Okay, I'm
not a dick, so that's more
rewarding.
Well then
[Music]
I'm a few